it is June 21st 2023 and you are
watching the code report the other day I
was doing some Modern programming by
having chat gbt do all the work for me
but it kept complaining that it failed
to scrape stack Overflow to get the
latest answers this forced me to go and
use the actual website like some sort of
caveman but in doing so I discovered
that the 2023 stack Overflow survey
results are in over 90 000 developers
filled it out and the findings are
encouraging terrifying and just plain
weird first up let's find out if you
actually need a degree to become a
professional developer my boot camp told
me I could make six figures after six
weeks of JavaScript training but in real
life it looks like 75 percent of
professional developers have a degree
that's an overwhelming majority but it's
still impressive that a non-trivial
number of people can get into this field
without a degree like you don't see a
lot of self-taught brain surgeons
Landing a job straight out of boot camp
but in some cases programmers can make
as much as surgeons you just have to
learn the right programming language
according to the survey you definitely
shouldn't learn PHP or Dart unless you
want to be poor you'll actually make way
more money as an HTML programmer because
it's a far superior programming language
at the very top of the salary tier
though we have Zig a modern low-level
language that I'll make a video about
soon but keep in mind this data is a bit
skewed because there's only three or
four paid Zig programmers in the world
and the same goes for erlang and F sharp
the highest paid in demand language is
surprisingly Ruby and almost every
language on this chart had a salary
increase of 10 or more from last year
almost enough to make a dent in the
Raging inflation that made us all way
poorer over the last few years a few
languages though experience salary
declines and even the highly popular
rust is down 35 bucks and speaking of
rest let's now look at some of the most
popular Technologies JavaScript is the
king when it comes to actual usage but
Which languages do people actually
admire and desire what you're looking at
here is a new chart on the survey that
replaces the loved and dreaded chart on
previous stack Overflow surveys when you
have a red dot far to the right it means
the language is highly loved by people
who actually use it when you have a blue
dot far to the right it means it's
highly desired by people who haven't
used it or in other words it's hyped up
rust is by far the most admired at 85
percent but there's been a lot of
political drama in the rust ecosystem
recently and it'll be interesting to see
if that number declines next year other
standout languages include Elixir and
Zig while the most hated languages are
Matlab and Cobalt of the highly desired
languages ehp was the least admired
which is surprising because they give
out free Lambos when it comes to Cloud
platforms AWS dominates but hetzner a
German company is the most admired
what's interesting though is that people
now absolutely hate Heroku I think the
lesson to be learned here is to never
get rid of your free tier when it comes
to JavaScript Frameworks react gets most
of the action but svelte is the most
beautiful I Concur and if you want to
learn svelte my full course will be out
next week for fireship pro members it's
also worth pointing out that newer
Frameworks like quick and solid are also
highly admired when it comes to full
stack meta Frameworks nexjs is dominant
but currently people on Tech Twitter are
revolting against the app directory
which might affect its ranking next year
I don't think it'll get anywhere near as
bad as Gatsby though which is still very
much hated even though it was acquired
by netlify last year when it comes to
non-javascript Frameworks Phoenix which
is based on the Elixir language is well
above everything else now in other tools
the mobile app framework Towery which is
based on rust is by far the most admired
but flutter is the most desired mobile
app framework even more so than react
native now moving on to Ides the S code
dominates our desires but neovim is the
most admired and it's a great editor if
you'd love to configure things so you
never have to actually build anything it
doesn't matter though because AI will
soon be doing all the building anyway
chat EPT is the most admired and desired
llm and same goes for GitHub co-pilot
which itself is based on the same models
as chat EPT but surprisingly nearly 30
percent of developers plan on never
using AI at all and another crazy stat
is that only 16 percent of people now
work in person full-time almost everyone
is either remote or hybrid remote
despite all the Articles you read about
people being called back to the office
okay so that was a lot of data to
process but I want to finish off with a
piece of data that reveals the secret to
making more money as a programmer a full
stack developer in India makes about 17K
per year in Germany it goes up to 69k in
the UK it goes up to 74k in Canada
you're looking at 81k but in the United
States of America it almost doubles to
140k if you want to make more money just
respawn in America next time this has
been the code report thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one